depuis l'annnonce du gouvernement
fédéral d'interdire l'importation des
armes de poing les ventes ont explosé
depuis deux à trois ans j'ai jamais vu
de cette quantité d'armes
dernier
les demandes proviennent essentiellement
d'amateurs de tir sportif vous dirais
que j'ai bien dû 400 % 2 qu'est ce que
je veux a normalement au moins quatre
fois j'ai des armes qui lui sont posées
2 3 cette interdiction est une étape en
attendant l'adoption du projet de loi c
21 le néo sécurité publique tino
s'attaque à la violence potentielle
éventuels qui pourraient être menées
avec des armes qui sont détenues
légalement par les soigner soit un
canadien donc par exemple on parle des
suicides d'accidents
le turinois c'est ça ne s'attaque pas
vraiment sur la violence qu'on voit dans
les rues des grandes villes canadiennes
car pour lutter contre la violence armée
il faut aussi lutter contre le trafic
d'armes illégal dans la fédérale 1 g/t
des sommes à la frontière je parle d'en
mettre plus mais ça c'est à court terme
à long terme il faut donc changer les
conditions de vie des communautés sont
affectés par sa violence heures pour les
survivants de la tuerie de polytechnique
la prof doit aussi être globale il faut
travailler au clan de la sécurité
publique à la prévention du crime à
réduire les influences des dingues
d'armé faux travail en santé mentale
mais il faut travailler aussi un
contrôle des armes à feu et c'est
l'ensemble des mesures qui va assurer la
sécurité publique des canadiens si les
ventes ont augmenté durant les derniers
mois la crainte de voir émerger un
marché noir est invoquée par cette
armuriers mais d'un cadre les personnes
vont devoir avoir déjà tourné par le
marché - et un air de marché noir
personnes croient savoir qu'ils que les
hommes y tue légale d'avoir des âmes pis
qu'elles sont des hommes qui se
promènent au caire on ne soit rompu à
l'heure où les fillettes se multiplient
le contrôle des armes à son avance par
étapes une mesure à la fois en attendant
de franchir ou pas le vote à la chambre
des communes ici s mitraillette radio
canada montréal